n'est pas c'est une honte vraiment je te
le dit les yeux dans les yeux et parfois
tu es vraiment un énorme connerie dire
oh c'est pas grave toi tes racines c'est
pas grave et quels terrains s'y sent pas
le fruit c'est toi et reims elle si j y
ai attaqué le 6 mai lors d'un homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bones voix contre et deux abstentions le
conseil municipal de grenoble a adopté
l'autorisation du port du burkini dans
les piscines municipales de la ville que
la polémique à grenoble et respirent les
officialisent qu'il proposera à
l'autorisation du burkini dans les
piscines le 16 mai prochain cette
réforme prévoit aussi l inverse
l'autorisation du monokini pour les
femmes afin de lever certains interdits
vestimentaires
alors le burqini les seins nus
finalement autorisé dans les piscines
municipales
aimez-vous cette décision
je remercie avec les directions et des
rédactions de causeur qui nous arrange
remercie elisabeth ben jawad cirad ya un
flux en ceci qu'ils portent le burqini
quand elle va à la piscine radhia qui en
français magnifique
alors je voudrais avoir ce qui d'abord
soutiennent cette décision soutenue oui
c'est une grande décision pour la
liberté la liberté des femmes et est
aussi une femme musulmane me disais
aussi pour les enfants parce qu'à plein
d'enfants qui ne pouvait pas être
accompagnés par leur maman est donc
enfin ces enfants j avais pas pensé mais
c'est vrai enfin ces enfants pourront
aussi aller à la piscine en norvégien la
en suède vous pouvez même loué un
burqini pour aller à la piscine à rennes
ça se passe très bien donc c'est une
très belle décision alors elisabeth vous
n'êtes pas d'accord non je ne suis pas
d'accord alors d'abord je voudrais
commencer par dire que je n'ai
absolument pas la moindre animosité
personnelle contre des femmes qui le
portent ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que l'égalité entre les individus
et sacré d'accord mais cette égalité
entre les individus ne suppose pas que
sur le sol français il y ait égalité
autres une pratique culturelle les
musulmans sont tout à fait les bienvenus
dans ce pays ils sont arrivés plus tôt
plus tard que les autres et c'est une
minorité et minorités vous avez deux
solutions la solution suédoise puisque
gilles verdez incité la suède où
d'autres pays
multiculturaliste qui met toutes les
pratiques à égalité ça marche pas très
bien on pourrait même il ya
l'assimilation républicaine
c'est à dire à rome tu fais comme les
romains les moeurs françaises la
minijupe même ligne et juin n'a pas le
même statut que votre burkini parce que
votre burkini n'est pas français vous
vous êtes française mais votre burkini
ne l'est pas il y avait quelque chose
contre l'islam je pense moi ce que je
vais vous dire déjà c'est que le burqini
n'est pas une histoire on va dire ne
concerne pas que les musulmanes ce n'est
pas de base il a été créé par east
australienne donc rien à voir avec avec
une femme de arabie saoudite ou de lire
en tout cas je fonde sur tout le temps
ces exemples exemple la cyber qui naît
le conte ce n'est pas porté que par des
musulmanes aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui ne sont même pas religieuse
croyantes ou enfin qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la religion et qui le porte juste
savoir quand même ça c'est rare mais ça
existe pourtant quoi il est interdit au
maroc d'après vous je ne suis pas
enseignée sur ses biens il est interdit
au maroc pourquoi parce que les
marocains savent que c'est une arme si
vous voulez de conquête des islamistes
alors j'essaie une heure de conte 4 vous
qu'a fait eric piolle c'est tout
simplement scandaleux et même vous vous
devriez vous être être pas content sur
ce qu'il a fait parce qu'il vous a mis
des femmes aux seins nus à côté de vous
je trouve qu'il ya un bordel qui
s'organisent ces fameux l'imprimerie
abordait ce qui s'avère parce que si je
trouvais bien normal que si on accède à
des femmes ça colle parce qu'ouvrir bas
on peut aussi accorder à des femmes 2 et
nan ça ne colle pas il ya des moeurs moi
je veux pas de voir des femmes au sein
des nations
dites que le ben oui j'ai alors que les
gens mais se heurtent qui à part les
gens qui ont passé à tabac samedi lors
de la conférence m'a dit pas non pardon
mais on n'est pas par un brasseur 80%
des français plus qu'ils sont contre
rigueur importe on parle de sondage il
ya rien mais gênant dans le burqini
c'est un progrès social les femmes
d'être beaucoup de femmes qui ne se
sentent pas à l'aise d'aller à la
piscine parce qu'elles ne veulent pas se
dénuder partiellement et qui aujourd'hui
grâce aux burqini pourront à la peine au
quiz c'est une avancée sociale gorille
du grand place
aujourd'hui fini pour moi ce n'est pas
un vêtement neutre je n'ai rien contre
les femmes qui veulent le porter en tant
qu'individu je dis juste que c'est un
message politique et de la même façon
que je n'aimerais pas que des gens
viennent avec des maillots avec la tête
de mélenchon de marine le pen dans deux
clips sivac sont pros vaccin et
que tout le monde se mec sans la figure
à la piscine municipale ce qui n'est pas
le but on vient là pour se détendre et
donc c'est pas un endroit pour faire un
meeting politique ou religieux je suis
d'accord mais je vous signale que le
burqini il est parfaitement légal la loi
est du côté du burkini quand les uns les
autres quand les villes avaient voulu
interdire le burqini sur les plages en
2016 tous les arrêtés avaient été
retoquées donc vive le burqini bocsa
vous verront là qu'est ce que ça vous
dérange que vos enfants soient dans la
même ici
même une seule et même avec des saint
des saints du à la piscine topless à
côté de vos enfants a franchement oui
oui mais voilà et comment vous partez
vous diront que c'est grand comme ça
comment bouger je fais pas les enfants
classes là j'en sors d'un émoi
les applications de rencontre il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui s'amusent à
retoucher leurs photos
j'ai déjà fait des rencontres ça s'est
très mal passé temps après c'est
vraiment la voir en vrai c'est vrai que
petites canettes d'un mètre 60 et
auxerre c'est assez marrant
typiquement
une humiliation devant un million de
personnes est arrivée dans cette
émission tournée les anciennes émissions
quand même donc elle n'est pas débile
donc c'est que elle elle a peut-être
cette force de vivre cette expérience
et si lui il veut s'humilier tout seul à
l'insulté devant la france entière est
passé lui l'idiot du village malgré tout
les lis ça laisse des traces et malgré
tout je pense à duras y compris sur les
réseaux sociaux elle a dû recevoir des
aides alors justement que ça laisse des
traces et on va falloir christopher
c'est christopher a fait l'expérience il
était avec anaïs déjà la question que
tout le monde se pose
christopher
pourquoi vous regrettez d'avoir
participé à l'émission je regrette
d'avoir participé à l'émission parce que
clairement samama limite traumatisé j'ai
très mal vécu par rapport à mon poids
déjà par rapport à l'image qu'on m'a
donnée seatelli je me suis pris avant en
direct c'est
à la télévision que c'est ça qui t'a
cécilia quoi d'autre quitte à céder
retombée après en fait l'émission voilà
parce que quand on est une personne un
peu forte à la télé on ne peut pas
savoir à 6-6 grosses bestioles c'était
menaces de mort décidée mais il y avait
quand même des choses je te vois des
gros porcs
si tu commences à écouter les abrutis de
traite sur rue mais réseaux sociaux
personnes forcément
quand on m'a contacté parce que c'est
même pas moi qui voulais la faire on m'a
contacté on m'a dit c'est une émission
hyper bienveillante il savait que
j'avais des problèmes par rapport au
poids et tout est mis et en fait mon
image a clairement était peu mais ce que
c'est de leur faute parce que c'est
comment il ya des réseaux sociaux
surtout c'est pas la faute de la
production mais bien écouter pour moi je
trouve que 50 50 ans soit 1 50 50 parce
que moi par la suite on n'a même pas
appelé pour savoir si j'allais bien si
j'étais vivant
quand même après c'est vrai que c'est
pas là donc on reçoit plein de haine
pleine de menaces planent aussi en sort
dans la rue on te dit gros porc ou alors
par exemple tu t'es pris un râteau dans
la gueule sa parenté 6 me et au final
comblées final y'a pas de psy a pas de
sida une scie mais alors après on a plus
de souci à
[Musique]
se faire la question qu'on se pose
est-ce que vous êtes ensemble
aujourd'hui ou est-ce que non vous êtes
chacun de votre côté et les moutons
seront bien gardées ouais l'article de
répondre
à tout mettre à vendre au foot on est
restés en très bons termes donc on a
toujours des temps kodak même si je suis
un peu compliqué parce qu'une ampoule à
moi de lui avoir mis un vent fort c'est
bien sûr après on s'est expliqué
christopher toi c'était à nice tu as vu
un crush pour elle vraiment
n'était pas assis mais mon enfant et
touba ouais alors ben oui et anaïs savez
pas ce que c'est un mix et un amical
j'ai eu du temps ensemble je venais de
me séparer après maintenant parce que
l'enfant né
il est né à la drogue oui à la la quel
âge un arrière d'accord il s'appelait
comment cléophée cléophée et donc soit
vous vous en êtes où vous êtes
balla le c'est compliqué parce qu'il
travaille beaucoup et lavit - moi j'ai
mon bébé donc aussi on se voit pas
forcément avec qui part d'accor dans
le nord est donc vous n'êtes pas du tout
ensemble mais par contre ça peut arriver
un jour tu seulement la ja le baptême de
ma fille prochainement il va rencontrer
toute ma famille donc pouvoir peut-être
vous êtes d'accord c'est à marier au
premier regard
alors que le psg jouait sur la pelouse
de montpellier samedi dernier il était
demandé au joueur de porter un maillot
floqué aux couleurs lgbt dans le cadre
de la journée mondiale de lutte contre
l'homophobie
au portant tous se sont prêtés au jeu
soft 1 le milieu de terrain idrissa
gueye qui auraient manqué la rencontre
au dernier moment pour raisons
personnelles l'an dernier il avait déjà
prétexté une gastro entérite le même
jour le conseil de l'éthique de la
fédération française de football a
convoqué idrissa gueye pour obtenir des
explications c'est un truc de fou
doit-il être sanctionné gilles verdez
uni non ça prend une ampleur mondiale
mais moi je le soutiens moi je lui donne
raison au nom de sa liberté de
conscience d'expression de religion et
pour ça il est jeté aux chiens il ya de
la haine contre lui je trouve ça n'est
vraiment
pas une opinion il ne pratique pas leurs
mots faut bien c'est parce qu'ils ont
pratiqué facile dans soutien contre
l'homophobie c'est pas c'est pas une
opinion l'homophobie c'est un délit il
n'est pas là c'est une honte vraiment je
te le dit les yeux dans les yeux par
droit t'es vraiment un énorme konaré
arrêté non mais beaucoup vraiment gilles
c'est une honte
pour non c'est toi qui comprend
alors je sonne à expliquer votre nom
mais c'est ridicule il mais il ne milite
pas pour l'homophobie il refuse
d'arborer hausse sensiblement ses parts
à gilles g palois de finir mes phrases
cycle s'est tous bien c'est pareil plein
de joueurs en angleterre à liverpool les
joueurs musulmans on leur a permis de ne
pas jouer ça ne fait pas un scandale là
bas ça qu'ils ont leur site à part
condamné l'essai mais finir
du sénégal matheson qui a apporté son
soutien à idrissa gueye il a dit je
soutiens idrissa gueye ses convictions
religieuses doivent être respectées la
guerre le martyre il dit bien sûr il
avoue des dvd cd gallieni n'est pas de
ces interdits évidemment qu'il soutient
en effet pour cent gilles s'est passé je
suis pour salomon d'être sage il ne
répond pas sur mes joues pas tu t'es
pour que les
il est évident le moins sexuelle était
interdite puis 2-1 57e dérange pas ça
donnait aussi déviance là bas vous avez
là te dérange ou pas mais je réponds pas
à ça près ben voila tu répond j'ai noté
ce n'est pas parce que vous ne vous
mettez pas dans la tête des sénégalais
s'adresse cette histoire un affaire
d'état un scandale au sénégal parce que
ce n'est pas pareil qui si il y à des
mentalités il ya une religion au sénégal
à callac vacances pour cent ce sont des
musulmans et il faut rester deux jours
voilà voilà alors d'abord gilles excuse
moi mais vraiment est à gerber s'est
jamais vraiment tout le temps ici comme
l'impact que jamais dans les loges il
encore tu l'as déjà dit dix fois dans
cette émission c'est fou mais tous
veulent dire mais je reconnais que
j'aurais pu les conneries
sénégal s'est vécue différemment compris
les sables au niveau légal il recommande
donc enfin c'est ça en fait c'est du
racisme
c'est tout le monde qui l'insultent tu
rends compte que tu vas dire délire
c'est pas grave toi tes racines c'est
pas grave et quel terrain si sûr pas cru
c'est toi et racé si j ai un tag
artistes avaient aussi vous pouvez
battre alors énormément de tee shirts
était la lutte contre l'homophobie oui
si tu refuses de porter ça parce que
c'est contre tes valeurs c'est que donc
tes valeurs vont pour l'homophobie non
hélas micha je ne veux pas s'afficher la
timbale pour deux pour des cons non mais
c'est hallucinant
mais prison parce que tu es
insupportable mais arrêtez avec mépris
je débats avec vous j'essaye de ce débat
je débats contient des barres papa coach
est en face de quelqu'un comme ça qu'est
des positions supportable et on coince
insupportable parce que vous dérange pas
parce que tu essayes de résumer l'état
d'esprit d'un joueur que tu connais
importe que tu connais tu dois parler
mais qu'elle elle que c'est quoi le
problème le problème c'est que tu dis
n'importe quoi voilà c'est juste
effectivement mais j'aurais aimé que
c'est qu'ici c'est vrai qu'un joueur il
s'est expliqué ont pour le moment pas
dire entourage à dire que gilles et
homophobes mais en tous les cas des
joueurs s'est s'impliqué donc je vais
pas parler de partie vous êtes parti
vous êtes nerfs vous n'avez pas du tout
ce qu'est ce que vous pensez donc ça
s'il explique étonnant qu'ils adoptaient
très mauvais
je vois ces
tirs il a mélangé le hall des
personnes arrivant au téléphone et ça je
peux non mais écoutez l'honneur au
village aux
différentes options est ce que je vais
te dire tu prends ça trop à l'aller tu
prends fois trop à la lettre la caisse
ou alan est jeune il est winter la nage
mais n'en
arrête de gaza connaît bien gildas un
exemple de tolérance la non franchement
tu es dur avec gilles et l'aquila faire
personnellement
[Musique]
oui quels sont les symptômes de cette
maladie comment se transmet tel la
variole du singe proviendrait d'afrique
de l'ouest et ne connaîtrez aucun
traitement pour le moment à l'heure où
l'épidémie du coronavirus diminue cette
nouvelle maladie pourrait vite devenir
préoccupante
alors faut-il s'inquiéter de la variole
du singe qui se développe dans le monde
entier doit même se veut rassurante
quand même si les symptômes semblent
virulent le taux de mortalité reste
faible mais on va en parler dans un
instant
c'est quand même une petite galère cette
affaire la durée d'incubation étant
générale 2,6 à ses jours mais peut aller
de 5 à 21 jours la variole du singe
n'est pas une maladie particulièrement
dangereuse pour l'homme mais voilà c'est
ce qui est dit nathalie terre là à
l'instant t voilà les symptômes peuvent
durer de 14 à 21 jours et il n'y a pas
de traitement alors ça disparaît tout se
guident alors on va on va en parler jean
l'instant avec avec bono a été
apparemment recensés
en région parisienne en région
parisienne
c'est à dire là la personne peut-être
on dit on me dit apparemment la personne
fait de la télévision
de façon exceptionnelle il ya eu des cas
à l'extérieur du continent africain
comme ça a été expliquée
essentiellement lié à des animaux qui
ont été vendus en europe ou aux états
unis ce qui est aujourd'hui un peu plus
différent c'est que pour la première
fois en europe du moins il y à des cas
de contamination interhumaine c'est
sartre chose la contamination la plus
probable se fait avec un contact avec
les sécrétions biologiques et notamment
les lésions cutanées à est donc déjà
effectivement lorsqu'une personne est
contagieuse hélas comme vous l'avez vu
des véhicules ou des pustules sur le
visage on voit tout sait pas
l'intermédiaire de ses lésions cutanées
que l'on peut être contaminé la corde
alors il m'a presque quand même il
persiste une inconnue à sa voix est ce
que il peut y avoir une contamination au
moment des relations sexuelles c'est
comme vous l'avez dit il se trouve alors
probablement en raison d'une chaîne
épidémique que actuellement ça circule
essentiellement et ça concerne
essentiellement des personnes qui ont
des relations homosexuelles des hommes
qui ont des relations homosexuelles
possiblement parce que le premier cas
qui lui a été contaminé en afrique était
homosexuel et quand il est arrivé
vigilant durement quoi dire ce genre de
chose quand même pas sûr je veux pas je
veux pas non plus que les gens alors
qu'on n'a aucune certitude se met à
avoir une image des homosexuels parce
que ça va très vite on sait je connais
le ballon et on va se dire voilà maladie
des homosexuels et passer très
facilement alors bien sûr en aucun cas
c'est à dire que les cas humains qui ont
été décrits sa touche et les hommes et
les femmes à nouveau aujourd'hui il n'y
a aucun argument pour laisser penser que
la contamination se fait par voie
sexuelle mais pourquoi vous disiez les
deux hommes ça leur ballon j'ai dit que
actuellement qu'on va dire l'épidémie
semble avoir débuté avec des hommes qui
ont des relations homosexuelles
donc c'est qu'il doit pas nécessairement
parce que justement ils ont eu des
relations proches et donc ils ont été
probablement contaminés par la peau
voilà par la peau maintenant
effectivement persiste la question est
ce que c'est la peau qui les a
contaminés ou est ce que c'est les
relations sexuelles elle même et ça on
n'en sait pas
[Musique]
merci d'être là m'adapte manhattan et
d'amour on va revenir sur pour la
première fois sur la disparition de
quelqu'un qu'on aimait énormément bien
surtout si c'était un ami de ma mission
on pense à lui pratiquement tous les
jours sur la disparition de jean pierre
et c'est vrai nathalie que ça fait de
moi comment tu sais comment tu commences
à voir comment tu arrives à ce que je te
jure quand je vous ai vu avec toute la
famille lors des obsèques de jean-pierre
je pensais à toi sur dix et l'atelier va
se retrouver toute la tribu
tout seul et je me disais dans ma tête
je me dis comment elle va gérer on n'a
pas le choix donc mais j'ai la chance
d'avoir des enfants extraordinaires
qui essayent de protéger en maman un
maximum il faut pas oublier aussi les
deux premiers enfants de jean pierre je
suis là et olivier qui sont aussi
extraordinaire et qu'on est tous soudés
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
que sa présence est tout le temps là
j'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'il est
parti j'ai toujours l'impression qu'il
va franchir la porte une fois qu'il est
parti c'est un peu compliqué de vivre
donc je pense à plein de choses
mais il faut que je me batte pour lui
pas pardon je suis dit il faut que je me
batte pour lui faut que je me batte pour
les études pour mes enfants pour qu'ils
réussissent leur vie donc c'est ça qui
me donne le punch parce que je sais que
pour lui ses enfants c'était primordial
monsieur donc jeu et puis comme vous
savez je crois vraiment à la vie après
la mort moi je savais que
juste je savais que j'y vois des
pressentiments on va me dire que je suis
folle et tout ça mais je savais qu'ils
passeraient pas ses 72 ans et voilà il
est enfin voila je savais que ça serait
plutôt le coeur et la tête et je me suis
pas trompé malheureusement parce qu'il
est mort juste avant ses 72 ans il est
parti le 2 mars il allait avoir 72 ans
le 8 avril c'est fou c'est fou et ça ça
te stresse pas le savoir ça de 20,6 mais
j'essaie toujours de me dire dans ma
tête que je ne trompais toujours une
fantaisie
et plus fort que ça au mois de janvier
la femme pescade et surpasse cannes il
ya le plus de traces de cancer bien
évidemment quand on dit qui avait plus
de trace de cancer ça veut pas dire
qu'il est complètement guéri ça se fait
dans trois mois il y aurait nouveau
quelque chose mais il y avait plus de
trace de cancer donc
donc voilà donc j'ai d'ailleurs j'avais
j'avais appelé florent pagny parce que
je voulais absolument qu'ils sachent que
jean-pierre n'était pas mort du cancer
bien sûr parce que je veux que qui reste
sous bonne amie commune et florent pagny
et je trouve admirable
comment il est notions et je remercie
parce que ils donnent beaucoup d'espoir
à beaucoup de gens alors on est deux
mois après le ces deux mois que l'on
perd 10 nous a quittés mois et demi ou
deux mois et demi comment tu vas
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu arrives pas ce
que vaut ça ça qui arrive ou pas où tu y
as des eaux il ya débat il ya
jeu on survit comme on dit qu'on survit
portland jean guillaume avec le temps ça
va passer ben moi je trouve que plus les
journées passent et percé et j'y vois là
j'ai l'impression qu'il va franchir la
porte et la franchit pas mais mais il
est présent il est présent à côté de moi
il est ça je suis 100% sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]